One of the questions that a cognitive psychologist
would ask is, can we really multitask? Because that
has to do with focus and attention and that's
a cognitive or mental activity. Another question that a
cognitive psychologist might ask among these is about
the dog learning to salivate when the door opens
because what's going on here is the dog is
learning to associate the door opening with the food.
And that's a learning process, and that's also
the domain for cognitive psychologists. What's not the
domain for cognitive psychologists is how attachment changes
over our lives. That's more the question for
a developmental psychologist because it has to do
with change over time. Another question that would
not be one for cognitive psychology would be
mood and dopamine. That's the brain and how neurotransmitters
affect our behavior. That would be the question for behavioral neuroscience. The
shooter, and whether he's having a psychotic episode, and how competent he
is to stand trial is more for a forensic psychologist. Because that
has to do with his mental state and the legal question of competence.